oktober 1989 ende des universums 13 die
1 danke also ich sage das jetzt ja jetzt
das kannst du wirklich sagen warum ich
stimmte auch über das ist viel zu
traurig wie zu hart geht nicht dann
packen wir fröhliche musik darunter wir
können hier und da alles fröhliche musik
einfach unterlegen ich sage das jetzt
also ihr werdet alle sterben so jetzt
habe ich gesagt selbst wenn wir unsere
hausgemachten probleme wie den
klimawandel atomkrieges pandemien oder
den technischen fortschritt überleben
sollten dann macht uns das universum
selber irgendwann den garaus unsere
sonne wird für kosmische verhältnisse
schon sehr bald explodieren auch unsere
galaxie währt nicht ewig und selbst wenn
wir das alles irgendwie überleben
sollten erwartet das universum ein sehr
unerfreuliches ende aber das müssen wir
ja nicht unbedingt hinnehmen oder wir
sind immerhin die menschheit lasst uns
also einmal schritt für schritt durch
gehen ob wir das ende des universums
überleben könnten
es ist probiert es ist popstars live
interviews
erst einmal was brauchen wir denn alles
zum überleben was braucht leben das
haben wir übrigens letzte woche
ausführlich im ersten teil dieses doppel
videos hier erklärt da geht es um den
anfang des universums und ab wann leben
im universum theoretisch möglich war
wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habe
dann findet ihr das video hier übrigens
beide videos sind mit einem
augenzwinkern zu verstehen wir können
nicht mal das wetter in einer woche
vorher sagen geschweige denn was die
menschheit in vielen hunderttausend
jahren machen wird die kurzfassung des
ersten videos ist aber leben braucht
atome aus dem es bestehen kann und
irgendeine form des untergrunds auf dem
es existieren kann außerdem braucht es
eine möglichst gleichmäßige
energiezufuhr flüssiges wasser und in
unserem fall kohlenstoff und sauerstoff
und jetzt drehen wir die frage vom
ersten video mal um wie lange können
menschen im universum überleben der
erste ernstzunehmende mordversuch des
universums wird vermutlich schon in etwa
500.000 jahren stattfinden dann trifft
ein asteroid mit etwa 800 metern
durchmesser auf die erde zumindest
statistisch gesprochen aber vermutlich
kommt uns ein asteroid namens wenn du
schon in 200 bis 300 jahren zumindest
bedenklich nahe sollte er uns wirklich
treffen dann wäre es gut wenn wir es uns
bis dahin unterirdisch gemütlich gemacht
haben oder wir haben unser asteroiden
abwehrsystem optimiert denn an solchen
methoden arbeitet die wissenschaft schon
jetzt unter anderem übrigens auch der
gitarrist von queen mehr dazu übrigens
hier in diesem video über kurz oder lang
ist es aber eh gar keine so blöde idee
unter die erdoberfläche abzutauchen denn
die sonne wird in ca 400 millionen
jahren immer heißer das ist normal das
machen sterne von der größe der sonne
gegen ende ihres lebens häufig so aber
das sorgt auch dafür dass es hier auf
der erde etwas ungemütlich wird damit
kommen wir vielleicht noch irgendwie
klar aber wirklich problematisch wird es
in ungefähr 550 bis 600 millionen jahren
dann nämlich streiken die pflanzen
photosynthese wird auf der erde nicht
mehr möglich sein man könnte natürlich
versuchen das noch irgendwie künstlich
zu rekonstruieren aber ganz ehrlich das
lohnt sich nicht mehr denn den 850
millionen bis 1,1 milliarden jahren
dampfen hier auch die ozeane besser wir
suchen uns bis dahin einen neuen
heimatplaneten oder wir haben
generationen schiffe aufgebaut auf denen
wir dann durchs weltall fliegen können
dort hätten wir einen untergrund
sauerstoff und flüssiges wasser bis wir
soweit sind ist es noch ein sehr weiter
weg denn wir müssen vermutlich
künstliche gravitation erzeugen wasser
und sauerstoff endlos recyceln können
und eine unabhängige energiequelle
finden und ressourcen für unendlich
viele ersatzteile für das raumschiffen
natürlich auch aber wenn wir das alles
entwickelt haben dann können wir
theoretisch der erde winken wenn sie in
ca 7 milliarden jahren von der
sterbenden sonne zerstört wird
kommen wir jetzt kurz zu einem thema das
ich am liebsten die nächsten 7
milliarden jahre vor mir herschieben
würde und das ist die steuererklärung
das wäre aber gar nicht mal so klug denn
damit würden mir knapp sieben millionen
euro durch die lappen gehen statistisch
gesehen haben 90 prozent von uns nämlich
ein anrecht auf eine steuerrückzahlung
die im schnitt bei über 1000 euro liegt
viele von euch mich eingeschlossen
blicken aber wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
richtig durch was man denn jetzt wie von
den steuern irgendwie absetzen kann und
da kommt tax fix ins spiel diese app
hilft dir schnell unkompliziert und vor
allem unverbindlich herauszufinden wie
viel geld nun mit einer steuererklärung
erstattet bekommen würdest du und danach
kannst du dich dann frei entscheiden ob
du deine steuererklärung einreichen
möchtest oder nicht das ganze würde dich
dann wenn du das machst einmalig 39 eur
99 kosten mit unserem klotzen kannst du
dir aber nochmal 15 prozent rabatt auf
diese einreichung sicher das ganze
funktioniert tatsächlich am computer
oder smartphone kinderleicht und dauert
in der regel nicht länger als eine halbe
stunde taxis kümmert sich dann auch noch
darum die abgabe ans finanzamt zu
schicken und sorgte dafür dass sie das
geld dann schnellstmöglich auf eurem
konto hat wenn euch das gefällt dann
nutzt beim checkout meinen co trotzen
für 15 prozent rabatt und damit sicher
durch nicht nur den ersten teil eurer 7
millionen euro sondern unterstützt auch
noch diesen kanal vielen dank und
vergesst nicht dass ihr auch noch die
steuern der letzten jahre einreichen
können vielen dank an taxis für die
unterstützung bei diesem video und damit
zurück zum thema bevor die sonne die
erde zerstört müssen wir uns aber noch
einigen anderen kosmischen veränderung
wir stellen denn in vier milliarden
jahren wird die andromeda-galaxie unsere
nachbar galaxie mit der milchstraße
kollidieren die beiden bewegen sich
heute bereits mit einer geschwindigkeit
von 100 kilometern pro sekunde auf einer
dazu irgendwann vereinigen sie sich dann
zur na ja was eigentlich
zur milch dromedar oder zur an straße
naja ok es können wir es ja dann auch
überlegen wenn es soweit ist wirklich
gefährlich für das ganze aber
wahrscheinlich nicht denn es wird in
zeitlupe ablaufen und galaxien sind
größtenteils lagerraum es wird also
nicht zu zahlreichen sternen crashs
kommen langfristig gesehen ergibt es
sinn sich von diesen ganzen
lebensfreundlichen planeten unabhängig
zu machen das ist so ein überholtes
konzept denn spätestens wenn die letzten
roten zwerge sterben das sind sehr
langlebige sterne werden planeten alle
sehr sehr kalt und es wird dunkel denn
neue sterne entstehen nicht mehr da die
hierfür nötigen gaswolken wegen der
expansion des universums zu ausgedünnt
sein werden das stellt auch unsere
energieversorgung vor ein problem denn
die noch übrigen weißen zwerge das ist
ein recht totes stadium eines sterns
strahlen nicht mehr viel energie in form
von licht ab aber vielleicht haben wir
bis dahin ja endlich diese kalte
kernfusion entdeckt deren realisierung
ist doch schon seit ewigkeiten nur noch
30 jahre hin oder sicherlich haben wir
das in ein paar milliarden jahren gelöst
über kurz oder lang müssen wir auf jeden
fall energie autark werden denn auch
weiße zwerge werden irgendwann erlöschen
schleichend beginnt dann die ära der
schwarzen löcher sie verschlingen nach
und nach sterne und sich gegenseitig
dagegen erscheint der asteroid vom
anfang des videos für einen spaziergang
die rotationsenergie von schwarzen
löchern ist jetzt die einzige
gleichmäßige energiequelle im universum
für niedere lebensformen die ganz wenig
energie brauchen reicht es vielleicht
noch wir menschen werden uns aber
vermutlich eher über kernfusion in
unseren generationen schiffen versorgen
müssen wenn es uns dann überhaupt noch
gibt in etwa zehn hoch 19 jahren werden
weniger massereiche sterne aus ihren
galaxien geschleudert und die schweren
die nicht entkommen können werden von
schnell wachsenden schwarzen löchern
verschlungen das liegt an einem phänomen
bei dem sich die kinetische energie
zwischen objekten ausgleicht wenn sie
gravitative aufeinander einwirken
schwere objekte werden langsamer leichte
schnell an das solare objekte verhalten
sich dann irgendwann fast genauso wie
gas teilchen auf einer viel größeren
scala und folgen der sogenannten maxwell
bolsmann verteilung in zehn hoch 21
jahren werden sich dann vermutlich
schwarze löcher mit der masse ganze
galaxien bilden stück für stück
verschlucken sie im laufe der
jahrmillionen die letzten sterne und
wenn wir nicht aufpassen auch uns wenn
wir also nicht alles an bord unseres
generationen schiffs haben und komplett
recyceln können war es das
allerspätestens jetzt mit der menschheit
was nahrung und sauerstoff angeht gibt
es aber hoffnung auf der iss wird
derzeit ein system getestet das
sauerstoff herstellen können soll und
pflanzen ganz autark ohne sonnenlicht
anzubauen wird bereits in der antarktis
getestet wasser soll auch recycelbar
sein schwieriger wird es jedoch bei der
energie die kommt bei da ist ja noch von
der sonne sterne gibt es aber in 10 hoch
21 jahren nicht mehr und wenn ein stück
für stück alle materie von schwarzen
löchern verschluckt wird dann gibt es
auch keinen nachschub an brennelementen
für die kernfusion mehr die energie wird
also zum immer größeren problem wir
müssen sie entweder vollkommen recyceln
können oder irgendeine andere
energiequelle im universum finden bloß
viel bleibt da nicht mehr wenn ihr jetzt
denkt lebens unfreundlicher geht es ja
eigentlich nicht mehr dann denkt sich
das universum oder genau genommen ist es
gerade erst mit der grundschule fertig
und fängt jetzt erst so richtig an denn
auch schwarze löcher bestehen nicht ewig
durch die hawking strahlung lösen sie
sich langsam auf übrig bleibt ein haufen
teilchen wie elektronen und positronen
nicht einmal protonen sind da noch mit
von der partie selbst für den
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass sich
menschen noch zwischen den schwarzen
löchern in durchmogeln konnten würde ich
jetzt richtig schwierig zumindest für
intelligentes leben dass deutlich mehr
energie braucht als blubbernde einzeller
und die einzel da wiederum können sich
keine generationen schiffe bauen es ist
echt verflixt was genau jetzt mit dieser
super aus teilchen passiert das weiß
übrigens nicht mal die wissenschaft
selber das hängt davon ab wie das
kräftemessen zwischen der expansion des
universums angetrieben erst durch den
urknall und dann durch die dunkle
energie und der gravitationskraft
ausgeht die eine kraft drückt alles
auseinander die andere zieht alles
zusammen es gibt drei szenarien die
besonders häufig zitiert werden in der
ersten gewinnt die gravitation das ist
der big crunch eine art kosmische
schrottpresse hier inkludiert das
universum irgendwann und verdichtet sich
auf einen einzigen punkt und von hier
aus könnte es dann einen neuen urknall
geben der zyklus beginnt von vorne
wunderschön doch dieses szenario ist
leider unwahrscheinlich denn aktuell
dehnt sich unser universum immer
schneller aus wahrscheinlicher ist da
der big freeze das könnte man als
kosmische gefriertruhe bezeichnen denn
hier ist alle materie gleichmäßig
verteilt überall herrscht die exakt
gleiche temperatur und es passiert
absolut gar nichts mehr wie in einer
gefriertruhe eben erst in zehn fünfzehn
hoch 56 jahren wahrscheinlich noch viel
viel später könnte durch
quantenfluktuationen ein neuer urknall
entstehen retten uns diese werden
quanten also am ende vor dem ewigen
nichts das dritte szenario der begriff
könnte eintreten wenn dunkle energie
noch viel stärker ist als bisher gedacht
nach und nach treibt sie das universum
auseinander irgendwann den sich der raum
schneller aus als lichtgeschwindigkeit
laut manchen modellen werden irgendwann
auch alle teilchen selbst photonen
auseinandergerissen und das wäre dann
wirklich wirklich das ende allen lebens
so oder so es wird deprimierend ein
märchen mit und wenn sie nicht gestorben
sind wird die geschichte des universums
auf jeden fall nicht bloß dass wir das
eh nicht mehr erleben werden denn es
gibt keine möglichkeit wie wir bis zum
ende des universums überleben können
es sei denn natürlich es gibt andere
universen in die wir fliegen könnten
[Musik]
aber bevor jetzt alle die taschentücher
raus kramt wie schön ist es doch
eigentlich gerade jetzt zu leben auf der
erde die uns alles bietet was wir
menschen zum leben brauchen auf der wir
vor der kosmischen entwicklung für den
moment relativ sicher sind in diesem
sinne bleibt neugierig patrick